hello everybody we have a life thing
going on right now over on the twitch
channel where I'm streaming amnesia
custom stories for your entertainment so
click the link in the description below
to be taken there right now to watch me
scream in terror click click click the
link click the link click the link click
click the link in the description below
and I'll see you there I'll see you
there
just click click link it's live it's I'm
it's happening right now
click click the link it's right there
it's in the description says twitch
twitch TV slash mark Blier twit click go
ahead and click that because nothing's
happening here go ahead and click it
it's okay you can do it just move your
mouse and um
click click the link any any second now
five over there you know it's not gonna
be there forever whereas this is so
click the link so click that link in the
description below I'll see you there
click it's right there you is it's right
there click it click it click click the
link it's it's um is your mouse okay um
is your internet working on your nails
probably it's it's you know it's purple
kind of maybe purple I don't know
depending on your browser um might be
blue you know if you're if you mouse
over it turns into a little finger thing
and you press the press that button on
it and you look it'll take you there
don't need to type anything at all you
know it's right there I couldn't put it
as an annotation cuz done let me but
it's right there so
like I said it's not gonna be up forever
more time you waste here less time you
waste seeing me play a video game you
know it's one of the other you know egg
flick and you could click the Lincoln oh
yeah I didn't really have anything
planned here so if you're expecting
something zany to happen I it's not
click a link in the description below
now that's things Amy you know if you're
missing this this is over there
kind of awkward you do staring at me
anyway
um should probably click that link you
know cuz it's things are happening over
there fun stuff you know maybe I'm
screaming like a little girl but you
know it's all not here through that link
your link is short for hyperlink link is
also main character in Legend of Zelda
link I put links to do a website
dumbest I'm just surfing the internet oh
I don't know we're still here
you could do anything you know
besides stare at me including clicking
that link right there it's some it's fun
it's great fun clicking the link you get
the haptic response of the button going
down and making an audible click some
pressure all right let's make an
exercise
whoo follow my finger with your pointer
follow it follow my finger with your
pointer follow it oh oh we're going oh
no it's going down click and click okay
is that too fast here we go follow the
finger will fall fall fall did you do it
you didn't do it can you still hear all
right so alright you know like I said
that life ring you know we're already
few minutes in you should probably get
over there cuz your fun times you know
and not fun times here alright well I'm
gonna go away now so thanks for stopping
by really creepy just staring at me like
that so thanks for watching see you
there okay if you missed it links right
there down there okay
bye bye bye
why are you still here there's a
livestream going on don't you know that
you could be watching that instead of
this just just wanted to say in case you
didn't know
why are you still here
there's a large stream going on
you could be watching it and having fun
and talking with me
what do you want from me
this is highly unorthodox
Oh
wanna have a staring contest
no I lost well I was fun you know
I was fun
I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I've got a livestream to do you know I
should probably get to it so
bye-bye-bye
last chance to click that link get it
out of here go see me over there can't
just hang around in front of my computer
all day can I got stuff to do okay bye
yeah